ra toile d'araignée citrouille et
corbeaux ont pris possession du parc
france miniature pendant leur tour de
france les visiteurs ont pu participer
au jeu de piste organisé spécialement
pour halloween qui faisait la fête
d'halloween et en même temps c'était une
histoire de découvrir un peu la france
mais en tout petit c'était une
découverte là d'avoir halloween sabah ça
fait un petit plus au niveau du parc
lors de la balade une gargouille un
pirate une druidesse est un peintre
maudit donne des indices aux passants
pour aider la sorcière à faire sa potion
magique c'est la troupe focus qui pour
la troisième année consécutive s'occupe
des animations jeux représentent un peu
le peintre maudit en même temps dorian
gray un petit mélange donc j'ai
l'immortalité mais j'ai une un peu une
double face un peu sombre un peu obscur
et heureusement les enfants sont là pour
me redonner joie de vivre donc je leur
propose des petits tours de magie de la
jonglerie aussi bien avec des couteaux
qu'avec un diabolo qui s'envole dans les
airs une saison qui s'achève à france
miniature avec la fête d'halloween les
portes du parc se fermeront en novembre
c'est l'heure à présent de tirer le
bilan de l'année avant sa réouverture au
printemps on arrive quasiment à la
fermeture on est très content on a fait
une très belle saison malgré des
épisodes de canicule qui sont toujours
un petit peu compliqué sur les sites de
loisirs
on flirte avec les 200 mille visiteurs
donc cette année c'est une très belle
performance
un bilan en hausse par rapport au
précédent de l'année pour france
miniature